قرابه المليون ونصف المليون تركي يعيشون
في المانيا يحق لهم المشاركه بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه وهنا امام القنصليه
التركيه في برلين صفوف طويله من الناخبين
يصطفون للادلاء بصوتهم اصوات الاتراك في
المانيا تذهب بمعظمها بحسب اتجاهات
التصويت في السنوات الماضيه للرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان ومع ذلك هذه المره كانت
المعارضه حاضره هنا وان بصوره خجوله معظم
الاتراك في المانيا الذين قدموا بعض الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانوا مهاجرين عمال
ومكثوا هنا كثيرون منهم ما زالوا يشعرون
بارتباط قوي مع تركيا وكثيرون ايضا خاصه
الكبار في السن لا يحملون الجنسيه
الالمانيه حتى
اردوغان لديه صوره القائد القوي الذي
يمكنه ان يواجه الغرب والاتراك الذين
يعيشون في المانيا يحبون هذه الصوره وكذلك
هم لا يتاذون من الوضع الاقتصادي في تركيا
الواصلون الجدد الى المانيا من المعارضين
السياسيين مثل حسين ديمير واجوزان البيرق
الذين لجاوا بعد الانقلاب الفشل ياملون ان
تحمل الانتخابات في تركيا تغييرا قد ينعكس
عليهم
امل ان تفوز المعارضه فهم وعدوا بانهم
سيحترمون حقوق الانسان ويعيدون العمل
بالقانون وهذا يعني ان كل الاتهامات
الباطله سيتم رفعها وسيصبح القضاء مستقلا
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج تشكل قرابه
الثلاثه نصفهم يصوتون في المانيا ما يعني
ان اصوات الاتراك هنا قد تحدث فرقا في حال
كان الاقبال مرتفعا وهو ما يبدو الحال
عليه هذا العام راغده بهنام العربيه برلين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات